maxime est débordé avec les enfants
lorsque son cellulaire sonne il qui est
un oeil sur son écran le numéro commence
par 2 3 9
comme le ciel c'est sans doute une de
ses connaissances ils répondent mauvais
surpris un inconnu lui annonce en
anglais de la gagne 3
furieux maxim rakov quand il a terminé
avec les enfants il compose le numéro
d'août provient la peine nouvelle
surprise
un homme lui répond gentiment en
français cette fois plutôt interloqué
maxime lui demande pourquoi il vient de
l'appeler mais je ne vous ai jamais
téléphoné lui répond là les deux ne
comprennent rien à ce qui se passe pas
étonnant ils ont été victimes de la
justification téléphonique
c'est un stratagème qui permet de
masquer il provient d'appels
téléphoniques en faisant afficher un
autre numéro
et cet autre numéro peut très bien être
un numéro réel le mien ou le vôtre par
exemple des télévendeurs utilisent ce
truc au mépris des règles pour que vous
répondiez à leurs appels sans vous
méfier le fin mot de l'histoire
décidément on ne peut plus fier rien
même pas à un afficheur téléphonique